avez-vous déjà fait appel à un devin moi
oui j'étais en Chine avec ma sœur ma
sœur avance et le devin lui dit l'an
prochain vous aurez l'amour la gloire et
la beauté
moi je veux que c'était je me dis pas
moi aussi je veux savoir
donc j'avance
je demande juste un métier
mais là le devin me dit
pour vous ça va être compliqué
peut-être dans 6 mois peut-être en mai
j'étais abattu
mais en même temps moi pour être honnête
les deux vins
j'ai jamais vraiment cru
jusqu'au jour
où tous les cabinets de conseils un par
un me refuse
à la fin il m'en restait plus qu'un
j'étais abattu
et dans ces moments-là mais qu'est-ce
que je fais moi je me suis toujours
réfugié dans ma passion la mienne ça a
été les échecs alors je suis parti en
Hongrie faire un tournoi d'échec pour
tout oublier
jusqu'au jour ou un beau matin
le dernier cabinet de conseils m'appelle
et c'est oui
c'est oui mais ils sont un peu chargés
en ce moment et je ne pourrais débuter
quand mais la date exactement prédite
par le devant
alors là vous pourriez me dire tout se
termine bien
oui sauf que rien ne va se passer comme
prévu
ces cabinets de conseils sont réputés
pour faire vivre un calvaire
et
malheureusement je ne serai pas
exception
après un an j'ai commencé à développer
des des premiers signes de Burn Out une
fatigue permanente un stress qui était
juste chronique et une démotivation
totale
mon déclic
c'est quand j'ai commencé à perdre mes
cheveux
quand sous la douche
tous les matins vous
osez même pas en fait passer votre main
dans les dans les cheveux mais il faut
bien le faire et vous le faites et vous
voyez des dizaines de vos cheveux
tombés c'était plus possible
c'était plus possible de faire des
journées de huit heures jusqu'à 23
heures
c'était plus possible de d'être là à
22h30
et d'être dans le stress de est-ce que
mon manager il va m'envoyer une slide de
dernière minute
un dernier modèle Excel
c'était plus possible
j'étais arrivé à un stade où mon esprit
était dans une quête incessante de
productivité
pour gravir les échelons
mon esprit disait à mon corps mais
pourquoi tu parles les cheveux
on n'a pas le temps de perdre tes
cheveux
mon esprit disait à mon corps mais
il est 1h du mat Julien pourquoi tu
t'endors pas on a une réunion à 8 heures
demain
j'étais arrivé un stade où en fait
mon esprit voulait dicter sa loi
mais mon corps n'était juste plus là
pour y répondre
et à ce moment-là
j'étais
au fond du trou
mais c'est là
que deux événements
extérieurs ont fait exploser la
popularité de ma passion les échecs
alors ces deux événements vous les
connaissez
le premier c'est la série le jeu de la
dame
et le deuxième ça c'est sûr que vous
connaissez
c'est le confinement
mais ces deux événements
ils m'ont rappelé droit au cœur que
j'avais une passion qui était toujours
là elle était toujours ici en fait mais
cette passion en fait
j'ai préféré l'oublier
parce qu'en fait les échecs qui m'ont
fait du mal
j'ai redoublé la seconde à cause des
échecs
et depuis je me suis toujours dit depuis
ce moment c'est nocif pour toi les
échecs faut que tu oublies il faut que
tu enterre ce rêve d'enfant
alors c'est ce que j'ai fait
j'ai préféré
enterrer ce rêve d'enfant
sauf que
quand j'étais au bord du burn out
j'étais bien content d'avoir redoublé la
seconde
j'étais bien content d'avoir consacré
autant de temps aux échecs parce que ça
m'a donné une lueur d'espoir ça m'a
donné une échappatoire ça m'a donné le
courage de démissionner parce que
j'avais un projet en tête
et ça ça m'a appris une chose c'est que
on doit se réconcilier avec son passé on
doit se réconcilier avec les décisions
qu'on a prises
parce que
quand vous pourrez enfin relier tous les
points entre eux
ce que vous voyez aujourd'hui comme un
échec sera peut-être Infiné la meilleure
chose qui vous soit arrivé
alors aujourd'hui vous pourriez me dire
tout se termine bien
bah oui je suis content de l'issue
compris les choses
mais pourtant à l'époque j'avais tout
fait pour éviter d'en arriver jusqu'à la
démission
j'ai même modifié ma personnalité pour
être un bon consultant
je suis toujours été de nature calme
réservé
on pourrait même dire introverti
dans ce cabinet on m'a dit Julien tu
parles pas assez en réunion il faut que
tu parles davantage alors j'essaie de
parler davantage
j'ai toujours aussi été dans l'affectif
dans l'émotionnel
et on m'a dit Julien ici c'est dur tu
prends trop les choses personnellement
on dur si toi alors j'ai essayé de m'en
durcir
en fait encore une fois mon esprit
disait à mon corps
mais ouvre la bouche parle on est en
réunion mais c'était pas naturel pour
moi
et mon esprit disait mon cœur mais
pourquoi tu sur-régis comme ça c'est
rien en durcie-toi mais encore une fois
c'était pas naturel pour moi
alors
j'ai fait du mieux que j'ai pu
j'ai essayé de m'en durcir j'ai cru que
le problème c'était moi que quelque
chose n'allait pas en moi que quelque
chose clochait en moi sauf que ces
défauts d'antan c'est devenu les plus
grandes qualités en tant que coach
d'échec dans le club d'échec que j'ai
lancé parce que être calme être
attentionné être à l'écoute et dans
l'affectif c'est des qualités
indispensables pour un coach d'échec qui
veut débloquer le potentiel de ses
élèves
et ça ça m'a appris une chose c'est
qu'en fait
on est tous des génies il faut se
réconcilier avec qui on est on a tous
des qualités exceptionnelles c'est juste
que parfois elle s'exprime pas dans le
bon contexte
Albert Einstein disait
si vous jugez un poisson à sa capacité à
grimper sur des arbres il va penser
toute sa vie qu'il est stupide
bah moi
j'étais ce poisson en fait qui voulait
grimper à des arbres qui n'étaient pas
les miens
alors qu'en fait j'étais juste fait pour
la vie marine
j'ai mis tellement de temps à me rendre
compte
alors vous pourriez me dire Julien c'est
si simple et qu'à faire ce qu'on aime
c'est tout
ouais mais est-ce vraiment si simple
quand on passe autant de temps à vouloir
rentrer dans des moules est-ce qu'on
perd pas l'opportunité de savoir
vraiment qu'il en est
moi mon moule ça a longtemps été mon
métier consultant
alors j'ai essayé d'exister à travers
mon métier jusque dans ma façon de
m'habiller jusque dans ma façon de
m'exprimer et même jusqu'à dans ma façon
de penser
dans ma façon de m'habiller j'avais un
code vestimentaire bien précis à
respecter tous les jours
dans ma façon de m'exprimer on utilisait
sans cesse des anglicismes on se fait un
coup après le petit coffre pour ketchup
c'était le genre de phrase que vous
pouviez entendre à longueur de journée
ça faisait cool
et dans ma façon de penser on nous
invitait sans cesse à réfléchir en
termes de rentabilité de rentabilité et
de rentabilité
mais on appelait ça et les gamins la
création de valeur
sauf que quand j'ai des missionné
j'avais plus personne pour me dire
comment m'habiller pour me dire comment
m'exprimer et encore moins pour me dire
comment penser
c'était libérateur j'étais enfin
moi-même
mais en même temps
j'étais devenu incapable de répondre à
la question qui es-tu parce que pendant
trop longtemps c'était ce moule qui
avait répondu pour moi
alors j'ai dû partir à la découverte de
qui j'étais sans jugement sans préjugés
une page blanche
j'en ai découvert des choses j'ai
découvert que j'aimais enseigné
transmettre mais mon moule m'avait
toujours laissé penser que c'était pas
une bonne voie à suivre j'ai découvert
que j'aimais des choses artistiques mais
mon moule m'avait toujours orienté vers
des choses analytiques
ça ça m'a appris une chose
c'est qu'il faut avant tout il faut
avant tout s'autoriser s'autoriser à
découvrir qui l'on est
sortir parfois du moule qui conditionne
nos actions et nos façons de penser et
peut-être aussi des fois laisser un tout
petit peu de place pour l'aléatoire dans
sa vie pour s'autoriser à découvrir des
choses qui sortiraient du cadre habituel
en fait
savoir qu'il en est c'est pas quelque
chose qui nous est donné c'est quelque
chose à aller chercher
aujourd'hui je ne perds plus mes cheveux
la santé est là et rien ne pourra
davantage me combler
j'ai l'impression de vivre sereinement
d'être libre de mes choix et d'y trouver
du sens
alors bien sûr
tout n'est pas rose mais j'ai le
sentiment de vivre pleinement
aujourd'hui
je suis maître international d'échec je
partage mon temps entre les tournois
internationaux et club d'échec que j'ai
lancé et je partage ma passion des
échecs à plus de 65
000 abonnés sur les réseaux sociaux
aujourd'hui en fait si je devais
repenser
au Julien d'antan j'irai même pas voir
ce devant
parce qu'à aller voir ce devin c'était
vouloir connaître l'histoire qu'on avait
écrit pour moi
sauf qu'aujourd'hui je veux vivre ma
propre histoire je veux écrire ma propre
histoire et ne pas vivre celle que l'on
m'impose
c'est ça qui fait qu'on est les auteurs
de nos vies et c'est ça qui nous rend
profondément humain
alors aujourd'hui je vous invite à mener
ce travail d'introspection
pour partir à la découverte de qui vous
êtes vraiment
une page blanche
sans jugement
et sans préjugé
peu importe l'issue vous serez gagnant
peut-être que ce travail d'introspection
il vous mènera exactement
à l'endroit auquel vous êtes déjà
aujourd'hui
mais vous vivrez alors avec davantage
d'énergie et de plaisir ce que vous
vivez déjà
mais peut-être aussi que ce travail
d'introspection vous mènera ailleurs
et que ce sera le point de départ de la
découverte de votre véritable potentiel
et vous serez enfin comme ce petit
poisson à nager au lieu de grimper à des
arbres qui ne sont pas les vôtres et
juste à vivre une vie
telle que ce que vous avez toujours été
mais que vous n'aviez jamais osé
découvrir merci
[Applaudissements]